[Music]
[Applause]
uh let's bring in michael wilbon pardon
the interruption
and uh of course we're trying to figure
this out mike
and i thought i mentioned at the
beginning of the show that i thought
this was coveted related
but i don't know if that's the sole
reason why kyrie irving
checked out from the nets like he
checked out
and then was involved in covet i don't
know why he checked out to begin with so
what do you think we're looking at here
with kyrie uh
and coming back
a big fat mess that's what we're looking
at
um and it is more than covet related i
mean
you hear all kinds of stuff dan i i know
you have quite the grapevine
as do i we hear all kinds of stuff as to
why kyrie's gone and where his head was
he didn't feel like playing blah blah
blah blah
and the bottom line is you're talking
about now
one of the least dependable players in
the league
certainly certainly one of the least
dependable
great talents in the league and hardin
now appears on that list as well
which is an interesting thing for
brooklyn nets and the reason that
the most people can't wait to see them
is not just because they got this
apparent super team but they got a super
mess on their hands where the first
future hall of famer you know
i love steve nash and mike d'antoni who
knows who knows where they can get their
arms around this
and most importantly kevin durant
because this all falls on kevin durant
now as well
a guy who kevin durant has proven he'll
play
if there's a threat that he winds up
leaving the court with one leg
kevin durant plays on blacktop of the
summer he plays on hardwood all winter
he just be plays and he's now got two
dudes running with him
who aren't committed to playing not like
he is
there was conversation yesterday uh we
had it here
when we got through with the show the
best threesome
that we've ever seen on the basketball
court and
and i know it's we we're we've got the
end result to back up when we say
hey rodman and pippen and jordan or
whoever it might be with your
ray allen uh pierce and uh
and and kg or bosch and lebron and
wade do you have a best big three
of all time
maybe what was called the original it
wasn't the original
uh but you know bird parish mchale still
pretty damn good yeah
right and and the thing is that was
talking about just the front line
as you know dan it didn't even include
you know dennis johnson for crying out
loud
or danny ainge two great players as well
um i i i still look at those and
you know i'm not well i am old enough as
a as a young kid
to have seen west
and baylor now they didn't win when
baylor was there because when they won
baylor had the knee injury and
but wilt west and baylor my god um so
i'm going back yeah
i'm going back um
certainly certainly lebron dwayne wade
and chris bosh won
two but that's not quite as many as you
mentioned jordan pippen and
and rodman or jordan pippen and grant
which i actually
coach i get chided by
well yeah yeah accu coach is a fourth in
there i mean so
yeah it's not going to be it's not going
to be as contemporary as the kitties
want
you know it's not going to be it's not
going to be what they would come up with
it's going to be something that's 40
years old but i would come up with steph
curry with
k.d and clay
okay like and then i throw in draymond
so if i i say you can throw in your
fourth
and and you want to put in cu coach with
rodman pippen and jordan
you know then that's kind of fun i don't
know what's going to happen in brooklyn
i know that we look at the individual
talent
but this isn't about individual talents
it's the individual talents meshing
together
to make it a team talent and that's
where i have a big question mark here
are there more concerns on the quarter
off the court in your opinion with the
nets
well you know i wouldn't have said off
the court until this week
and you know when you listen to i
listened to boogie cousins the other
night and
listen to john wall i mean they're just
wrong they're like what what are we
talking about we
we had we had a team here that had a big
anything
but they could have been a contender if
james harden was interested and he
wasn't
so now you got off the court because
there's although if everybody's where he
wants to be
but then if everybody's where he wants
to be what the hell is going on with
kyrie irving
um i i still think on the court
you know i i had before the season i i
was watching the preseason games in the
first couple of regular season games dan
and kyrie irving you're reminded when
he's out there and engaged
there's just no better ball handler i
mean there's no better ball handler
necessarily i'll still take
isaiah thomas but i mean they did we're
talking you know
we're splitting the finest hairs now
right yeah
but the averages is his career i got my
son is a kyrie irving devotee
this winds up leading to screaming
matches every night in our house
and um penny averaged more than five
assists a game
how can you be a wizard with the ball
and only average
five assists a game one night i made him
take out or go to basketballs.com i
almost said take out the basketball
encyclopedia
dating me further but i made him go to
the site and
read aloud john stockton's assist totals
every year in some years as you know
they were like 12 and 13
and kyrie can't get six and so
my my challenge was if kyrie irving this
was my
under if he's engaged enough to sort of
average
6.2 assists again which is half
of magic in stockton in a great year if
he's
half that interested in finding his
teammates yeah brooklyn they're
loaded they can they can do this but
now man i i i mean so what's his level
of engagement versus selfishness and
usually that doesn't work out well that
ratio um
i think they can probably become
interested enough to play with each
other because this is what they wanted
but now and they're going to have
everybody gun informed do they have that
constitution
kevin durant does kevin durant has that
do the other two have it and i i'm
thinking
no they don't is michael wilbon pardon
the interruption
co-host the person player who has the
most pressure on them this
football weekend is who
oh football weekend
man i gotta shift gears and go back to
that um
well i don't unlike a lot of people in
this industry who talk about the stuff i
don't think
the goat has any pressure i mean if he
loses so what does he like give back the
trophy the goat to somebody else no
so brady has i mean you know it's
relative to the others
brady has none brees has none i mean
roger's a little bit because people
think that the green bay should have won
more than one right and so i
i don't know that there's anybody up
you know maybe well jackson
i mean i know he's won he's won a
playoff game now but i think he's ahead
of josh allen and buffalo in terms of
what
people are expecting and i guess i'm
defining it there for dan
on what people are expecting out of
these playoff teams and the biggest
players on the teams
were we being fair though to the lamar
jackson situation where
he bowed out early in the playoffs two
previous years
but he just turned 24. i
he finally won a playoff game and then
people like he finally won a playoff
game like
he's 24. two years
yeah yeah yeah i don't think it was
you know we rushed to crazy brushes to
judgment now
you know he he's over his career okay
he's hoped for two
i mean you know i i
i know last year the losses were
surprising
um but i i
now i'm saying pressure for a different
reason he because this conversation has
taken place
and we have unfairly rushed now he's
there
you know he's sitting there now and
you're like okay who who do you favor to
win this game and if
you're playing favorites i know
buffalo's got to be i don't look good
but buffalo's got to be what a three to
four two to three point favorite at home
is that what it is dan yeah
yeah so i you know does josh allen have
actually yet no but he will if he
doesn't win this home game
we'll come in the next season saying oh
josh allen he hadn't gotten to a title
game yet
you know and i certainly don't think
it's kansas although you know
it's interesting to me that everybody
rushed to declare than the greatest team
of all time after
one one
i you know i'm down with that but i
don't think kansas city i don't think
there's any way
and i don't think cleveland has just not
even that much pressure
given what they've gone through given
how they broke through
so i i guess i guess i'm saying lamar
jackson which goes against everything
well we could have talked about the
bears mike so i i i spared you that
oh please thank you you i hopefully you
still like me enough
to spare me bears conversations i can't
do that too because they're so pathetic
thank you mike it's always great to see
you and uh thanks for joining us have a
great weekend
dan you do the same man appreciate you
having me that's michael wilbon pardon
the interruption co-host
there and uh we apologize mike's uh
internet connection was uh not as strong
as normal there so
uh we hopefully uh we got through that
okay